[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today up next
we have Jamie in San Antonio hey Jamie
welcome to the show hi thank you for
taking my call absolutely how can we
help if I needed a Dream Team to help me
you two are the ones I would pick we got
we are here for you Jamie we are here
for you what's up I need you I have a
very simple question in a very messy
situation um at what point do I stop
investing um kind of what's going on I'm
45 I'm disabled and I'm freshly divorced
um so I'm on a set income and I need to
start making a budget and I'm not sure
what to do with my money um I bring in
about 4,000 a month but I only spend
about
1,500 I'm debt free and I have um a
little over
$650,000 in brokerage
account 600 and what
50,000 50 good for you Jamie okay um
this
is from the divorce and okay I received
probably 90% he received maybe 10 if
that okay but I feel like I cannot make
any Financial mistakes because I cannot
go out and get a job um if anything goes
wrong I'm um I'm scared yeah Jamie I
want you to do me a huge favor I want
you to take as deep breath as you
possibly can and I want you to hold it
for a count of three okay do it take it
deep in hold it one two three let it
out okay I want you to I want you to
hear me as directly as you can okay
financially you're in great
shape okay
okay you're in great
shape I I could hear the words but I
just can't I know you can't I know but
when you get scared in the middle of the
night I want you to hear those words
what happened in your
marriage um after 21 years I found out
um he yeah he's he's been cheating on me
for a
while um he's recently admitted that he
has a sex
Edition uh so this been going on with a
lot of people huh a lot of people I felt
I I found out
um I couldn't I couldn't stay I couldn't
no um no no no no and my my kids are
broken and I'm broken and so on paper it
looks so good and I know that because
I've been Dave Ramsey since 2009 I'm
should have better than I deserve but I
am I can't I'm afraid I'm gonna make a
bad decision I'm afraid I'm going to
become a shopping addict um I I can't
eat my tions because I've I've had
bypass surgery I cannot drink alcohol I
can't smoke I I can't so I'm stuck here
having to deal with
this and I I'm I'm scared I'm I so I
have back to the question I have about
2,000 plus extra each month I have
650,000 in brokerage can I just take a
break can I just go on vacation when I
want to
or
what do what do I do yeah yeah oh Jamie
um how how recent was all
this um the divorce was Final um in
September okay so my rule of thumb I
always tell people is no big big
decisions for six to six months to a
year okay that that that doesn't mean
don't go out with your kids you only
need to go somewhere and just be
together I um had some medical issues
and I
I received we have two homes I received
both of them in the divorce I sold the
first one and I moved to 16 hour south I
had to get away from him okay I had to
move and I have my son with me and my
daughter is in college and she will not
talk with him she won't and so I'm
constantly like the in between and so
I'm covering every bomb that he throws
and the kids just don't know what he's
doing wrong and so I'm I'm worn out yeah
but then I'm
also keep
thinking at some point I'm going to
break and is it going to be a financial
bad decision is it going to be what is
it and have you broken before because
you keep mentioning control have you
have you lost control
before no I think it's a control issue I
can only control my money right now
that's not true that's hold on hold on
that's not true you can't control him
but you can control you have you have
you had struggled with addiction before
have you struggled with out of control
behavior before
my brother died of addiction last year
okay and so
I'm very um aware of slip Falls and I I
get that but is that you yeah I hear a
very strong woman whose entire world
just blew
up yeah and and Jamie one thing JN has
said and I've heard you say this before
which I feel like is so true right now
what I'm hearing from you Jamie is that
especially when someone walks through a
situation where 's been dishonesty
broken trust infidelity like anything in
that category the the spouse on the
other end questions oh my gosh can I
trust myself yeah you've lost trust in
you because I feel like I was trusting
him and then he comes up living this
completely different life how am am I
the crazy one you know like you you well
that's what he told me for years is I
was the crazy one and I made it all up
and I was manipulated for years by him
so he could cover it up yes which is
obviously the compl opposite of what's
going so Jamie all of that you are
sitting here and second guing yourself
on everything you know you're second
guing yourself that you're going to have
a shopping addiction because your
brother struggled with addiction but you
haven't struggled with addiction you're
trusting yourself that I'm going to
spend all of this money
$650,000 I don't know if I can trust
myself with money you can trust yourself
with money you've been doing this stuff
since' 09 of how to of how to handle
money well right so I want you again and
I don't even know how to like walk you
through that but I want to give you
confidence as a as a as a long-distance
friend that's met you for two minutes
tell you J you can trust yourself more
than you're giving yourself credit for
so just hear an outside voice say that
because you're questioning every part of
your life which is understandable like
hear me say that understandable but but
for someone on just the outside looking
in I just want to say that truth over
you that you can trust yourself okay so
you're not crazy I want to ask you this
question yeah you like repeat that to
yourself you're not crazy um you were
married to a sociopath who put you in
extreme danger by having multiple
multiple sex partners you didn't know
about and destroyed the trust that and
gas lit you the whole way so you're not
crazy now I'm gonna ask you some direct
questions are you g to blow all $650,000
of this
money no okay are you gonna take care of
your
kids absolutely every day okay every
second are you gonna honor and take care
of
Jamie I'm trying okay you are now you
have to have to Priority number one full
stop you have to get a couple of people
in your
life that will sit with you and have
coffee now that's gonna be very
difficult because you move 16 hours away
right yeah whether that's a a therapist
whether it's a counselor it's a local
church you have to have people with you
during this time and it cannot be your
kids they can't be the person who the
people who prop you up right right and I
would block husband I would take him out
out of my phone I would cut him off X Y
X there you go yeah thank you for
catching me on that one um and at some
point because he is such a out of
control dishonest person he's going to
at some point try to snake his way back
into his kids' lives and I want them to
have that he's already started yep of
course he has um I want you to have that
conversation with your kids that they
get to walk away from somebody who is a
sociopath
okay and that's okay I keep telling them
like you he's your dad and they don't
know everything obviously how old are
they 19 and 21 okay um there is a way to
tell the
truth without telling them that their
father is evil okay and or there there's
a way let me even let me rephrase that
even more there's a way to tell them
that their F their father has is is very
dishonest has had a pattern of
dishonesty has not told the truth put
you at extreme risk without saying your
dad sucks and he's a terrible person
right one of that is one of those is
just running somebody down the other is
just telling the truth about what
happened okay that's okay we're not
going to we're not going to dispar but
we're going to tell the truth okay all
that to say you got to get some people
in your life hang on the line and we're
going to give you three free months of
better help I want you talking to a
couns before tomorrow is over thank you
for the call thank you Jamie create your
free every budget today the simplest way
to budget for your life